herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
mit dir klar dass er dabei ist übel gut
altern ja wir wissen doch gar nicht so
wirklich was wir heute machen
das kommt denn da ja irgendwann als
geschenk alter der karten sogar ob dabei
versteht denn da drin
machen wir erst mal die karte auch
lieber luca ganz viel spaß mit dem spiel
für spionen und geheimagenten moment und
hier der arzt drauf und hier steht
werbevideo hat etwa toys 'r' us unsere
herzens firma leone schön und spaß toll
sagt ich hasse ihn gefeiert haben mich
angefragt für ein video und es handelt
sich um diese geschenke hier
ich würde sagen luca wir packen auf in
33 was hast du ich hab jetzt haben das
gleiche geil freut mich das spiel heute
das spiel
safeway denn die schlüsse die hinweise
zur messers kenn dein fingerabdruck 6
bis 99 jahre
warum wissen wir schauen mal was ich
hier finden wir haben wir einen projekte
liegen dass sowieso zum abhören yahoo
das ist gut schon mal okay wir haben
geld gold sogar gold altenstadt lag sie
bei 4 80 an der stelle also lieferumfang
ein safe eines stethoskop rk 1 915
münchen 18.4 sticker alles klar alles am
start ziel des spiels ein safe voller
diamanten und goldmünzen knackt den ton
an sie heranzukommen wer als erstes vier
münzen oder zwei diamanten gesammelt hat
gelähmt vom spiel öffnet die grau platte
auf der rückseite sowie sonnenschein
ja so dass das sonderheft und kräftig
ist der dienst youtube millionen erst
jetzt verschlägt ihr die safe tür vorne
steckt jetzt das kleinere ende des
stethoskop auf den center der leuchtet
rot wurde vier mal so ein bisschen ja
soweit das rote licht an der tür zu
blinken beginnt kann auch das spiel
beginnen da ist junge jetzt geht's
endlich los
ok ich spiele wird im uhrzeigersinn der
jüngste spieler beginnt dann bist du am
zug versuchst du den code ist safe zu
knacken welches ist die richtige zahl
bahnhof wird entscheide dich für eine
der ausliegenden karten und lege diese
vor dem altar auf dem balkon solltest du
wirklich locker dabei heute schließlich
ist irgendwann will man in maxi
schwierig weiß aber sind die karte geht
auch nicht wieder zurück im spiel sein
du hast ja nicht mal zum wetten gefragt
vielleicht zehn meiner bist du anzug
versuchst du den code des ace zu knacken
welches ist die richtige zahl entscheide
dich für eine der ausliegenden zahlen
daten und lege diese vor dir ab sie
geben nicht wieder zurück im spiel
sondern bleibt auch nach ende der eines
zuges beide lieben dann stellt sie
bezahlen oder die entsprechende zahl so
ein dass das file symbol auf sie zeigt
mit dem stethoskop prüft nun ob du die
richtige zahl eingestellt hast dazu
drückst du zunächst den großen trichter
des teleskops fest gegen den dann
nächste den finger auf den fingerabdruck
scanner und drückst drauf hier ist der
fingerabdruck scanner disco und hier
unten ist der fall also die mittlere
zahlen muss man einstellen freuen wir
jetzt gibt es allerdings einige
möglichkeiten was dann passieren kann
wenn es allmählich die falsche zahl ist
bleibt der safe verschlossen tochter
stethoskop gibt eine mit einem geheimen
hinweis
okay das ist krass die folgenden
geräusche sind an dieser geheimen
hinweises reiber in pink
das ist ein hohes geräusch das heißt die
richtige nummer ist höher als die uhr
eingestellt hast einen humbug
das ist ein tiefes getäuscht das heißt
die richtige mann ist tiefer als die wir
eingestellt dass eine polizeisirene
reißt so einhellig die eingestellt und
was falsch
leider bekommst du keinen hinweis zur
richtigen nummer eins und dann ist der
nächste spieler an der reihe
wenn man allerdings die richtige zahl
dann hat dann springt der safe auf und
nach dem zufallsprinzip fahren
zwei oder drei münzen heraus in dem feld
befinden sich verschiedene arten von
münzen und zwar drei verschiedene es
gibt goldmünzen von denen sind die
meisten darin vorhanden und man braucht
4 volt nutzen um zu gewinnen
dann gibt es die anden die sind sehr
selten dafür brauchen wir nur zwei um zu
gewinnen und es gibt eine alarmglocke dh
die polizei wird alarmiert und man muss
alle eben gewonnenen münzen zurück in
den stütz werden und die mütze mit der
allerdings aus dem spiel genommen
ok verstehen ja dann würde ich sagen
legen wir los oder einfach schlecht
anfängt sich der jüngere spieler yamaha
ich nehme zuerst mal die wunderschöne
zahl 14 weil sie 14 jahre alt was 14 ist
eingestellt und jetzt tue ich mir dann
auch einen fingerabdruck scanner
restauranttipps geräusch fifa ok und
polizei sie redet sie reden heißt ja
bekanntlicherweise kein hinweis ja ich
wähle die zahl 5 und die fünf lege ich
jetzt hier zu mir hin das heißt ich
werde jetzt hier die fünf aus sodann
hatte immerhin münster die einfach die 5
es war doch die von meinem ersten mal
bitte dich vorräte noch eine diamanten
oder drei gründen
alles gut danke danke danke schafft
freunde danke sagt beim ersten versuch
aber die richtige zahl erwarten ja dann
machen wir die zweite runde ja ihr seid
ihr dazu gemacht du darfst glaube ich
sofort weitermachen ich darf
weitermachen okay ich nehme mir jetzt
mal als erste zahl die 13
ja herr freitag der dreizehnte also die
13 das heißt die stelle sofort auf die
13 paar hier vorne drückt auf den knopf
auf den fingerabdruck scanner und ich
habe einen hinweis bekommen max ich weiß
jetzt zu sagen es geht ja bis 18 ist
daneben aber an die 14 jack kommt
vielleicht darüber ist polizei hatte
ja ich habe ja nur die polizei ist krank
ich nehme die zwei bei der damen und
herren ist echt ganz nice muss immer so
ein bisschen überlegen das so wir sind
noch den zwei freunde das heißt ich
packe das liegt wieder ein mentor und ok
ich weiß dass ich glaube es auch die 3d
ist eingestellt und polizei ich raste
aus ab märz mit dir also ich weiß dass
die zahl zwischen 2 und 13 ist dh die
einst ist es nicht die drei warst du
bereits schon gehabt das heißt ich nehme
jetzt als nächstes einfach mal die 4
ich glaube das nicht ich habe ja nur die
polizei ja was habe ich denn immer
wieder fällt jetzt auch geht
aha ok der zweite gewann jetzt weiß es
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die 6
ok ok mache mache ich also an meinem
gesicht wirst du nichts erkennen
er macht mich so färber 2010 als
weltmacht was ich habe gewonnen mal auf
die rückseite was hast du für einen
gehabt drei diamanten es gibt es gibt
noch fehler ich habe drei diamanten
was hast du hat in meiner zweiten
spielten den hass nicht ich habe glaube
ich nur die polizei sie wäre halt its ok
anscheinend hat luca mich jetzt einfach
komplett fertig gemacht welchen revanche
ok dann kriegst du da bist okay leute
jetzt wo wir das spiel verstanden haben
stehen wir noch mal eine schnellere war
dafür müssen wir die ganzen neuen münzen
um weihnachten ja irgendwann machen
jetzt sind alle müssten drin ich würde
sagen sie ist mal der früh anfangen auch
wenn du gerade gewonnen hast aber
gleichheit erfolg danke also ich fange
direkt an mit der 81
die relativ weite der mitte liegt kann
man zuschauen so die tendenz heute
hingeht
was soll da ich jede dieses gerät aber
nur eine münze
das ist echt nicht erst ist es nur eine
kündigung glaublich nehmen wir mal die 8
dieser tresor liebt mich einfach ich
nehme jetzt dass wir das wenig ist die
acht leben und es geht ab
ohne spaß ins bett und ich wette das ist
ein frank von ravensburger locker ist
das ein preis steht und ich wurde eine
dings muss die kamera ist dass die
kamera dass die kamera was ich habe die
ganze zeit nicht gesehen
ich lege die ich finde die vier würde
ich sagte ich sagen weil wenn ich jetzt
ein tipp kriege der nach unten geht dann
weiß ich okay der geht doch
er kann nicht zur ruhe da das heißt
jedes mal die vier eindrücke hier drauf
werde damen und herren und ich habe
einen tipp bekommen die fertig bringt
mich die gerade sehr krass weiter mit
fünf wenn er sich sehr krass weiter
bringt dann bringt das mich vielleicht
auch bald heute es in den zwischenraum
liegt und ok ich weiß bescheid
wer bei den tipp bekommen dass höher ist
das geht es fertig oder wird's polizei
die rede war wieder ich den 77 werden
daher könnte das könnte ich klein war
die achte man über polizeisirenen 7
polizei trug einmal prozess wenig hatte
nicht enthalten immer bis auf zwei mal
okay ich nehme die zehn mit der 10 habe
ich ein gutes gefühl und schnell spiel
okay
ja ich weiß das scheint interessant ich
nehme die zwölf meine damen und herren
wer kennt nicht die 12er gefunden
zwergenland
er kennt die faktor wenn wir sind nicht
kennen ja okay ich höre da man aber okay
jetzt weiß ich welche zeiten ich weiß
welche zahl ich weiß das ist nehmen die
aha und gehören jetzt mal was es ist es
ist okay ich weiß genau welche zahl es
ist deswegen liebe ich jetzt die 13
die 13 freitag der 13 bewährten
zündstoff
bringt mir glück meine war nicht in der
schweiz krank waren kommt was wollen sie
hier
die 16 habe ich ein gutes gefühl und
ordnung
der erste öffnende
ja unglaublich irgendwas ist da für
einen normal ok weiter war eine halle
goldmünzen krämer
ich darf wieder zu machen und ich darf
auch weiter spielen ich nehme ganz zu
begehen die zehn da ich ein gutes gefühl
bei der c natürlich meist ok und die 10
a ha jetzt weiß ich schon was es sein
könnte
okay okay was nimmst mich würde
tatsächlich an der stelle mal die der
zwölf nehmen wegen den zwölf werken von
zwergen
wer bringt mir nichts weiter als wir
gehen direkt auf die zwölf ich höre war
hin und gemacht ich nehme die 14
deswegen und haben heute ich sage ja ja
okay gut da habe ich schon mal so eine
grobe idee verrate aber nicht was es ist
heute ist der siebzehnte dezember werden
wir das video aufnehmen das heißt
freunde ich liebe die 17 länder
das ist zufrieden damit
okay da haben wir das richtig ist nicht
reinbekommen oder 2 verwandeln dann aber
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal wegen
freitag den 13
die 13 aha und guckt sich damit
vielleicht erfolg habe ok ok hat es
nicht geöffnet wie 13 war es anscheinend
nichts komisch trotz weiter gebracht
sondern ich würde tatsächlich dann an
der stelle rat werde ich die 17 hatte um
so nimmst die 13 was du hattest du
frustriert sind habe ich da gerade
gesehen das heißt ich nehme doch jetzt
mal die elf gegen elf pferde davon
erwerben müssen uns als zweiter sieg
das newcomer wie ist alle nehmen die
fünf am anfang erstmal okay mit älter
als jetzt für das komplette tipp also
jetzt wird s klasse als ich immer die 2d
mich wegen elf unbedingt noch diesen
sommer davon die 11 ich weiß es nehmen
die 16 wegen 66er nummer ja die 60 das
ist könnte dann würde ich natürlich
sagen dass ich einmal über die 15 nehmen
wir mal wie ich schon gegen 15.15 affen
und eröffnet sich dadurch so auch gar
nicht was auch ihre nachrichten
gegen 17 17 das heißt ich noch an der
stelle einfach mal die 18
würde sich mit der 18 eine münze was
jetzt einmal nichts gesagt weil ich
schon vier mal dazu sagen ich mach
einfach mal direkt an mit der 66 ledig
malaga da habe ich wurde ich hab so laut
geredet dass ich den typen nicht gehört
ich nehme das mal diskutiert sehen und
ist die polizei an der stelle
tatsächlich dann denke ich einfach mal
die zehn leben meine damen und herren
ich denke spanisch schon ganz gut liegen
könnte neben der trainer ist ob meine
damen und herren mit zwei ganz normale
sonst wird die ok für das schon wieder
weitermachen ich würde tatsächlich zu
beginn
ich habe die cd genommen und damit
leicht jetzt gut ich würde jetzt beginnt
auch mal die sieben nehmen der herr
deswegen legen sieben weltwundern und
gehört ganz kurz sind es sieben
weltwunder stärke dann nehme ich mal die
14 14 es stimmt ich jetzt an unserem
haus machen
sich zweimal jedes werk ist ein glück
ich weiß dass es die sechs ist mir bei
ihrem lager für die 2
ok wartet auch viele jetzt hab ich nicht
drauf geguckt denn das u3 x macht
zweimal gewonnen
die leute da würde ich sagen wenn euch
das video gefallen hat last liebend
gerne eingekleidet oder dreimal gewonnen
weil ich hier gold mit zwei diamanten
braker heißt das coole spiel ist vom
ravensburger und auch danke für die
unterstützung dass wir das wieder machen
konnten es hat tatsächlich viel spaß
gemacht allerdings dazu sehen und in der
beschreibung ja dann sind wir beim
nächsten mal wieder
und bis dahin tschüss